Good evening.
I'll give you one more try this gonna be a kind of
a give and take evening. Good evening.
I thought you might be awake. This is going
to be a great great night. And I'm glad that you're here. I
want to really quickly go over what we've talked about. You've heard
this so often I'm hoping you can do it yourself, but this
is the discipleship pathway everything. We
do here points people towards becoming
disciple makers and my prayer and
the prayer of all of our leadership is that we would not
just be people who have discipleship classes, but we
would actually be disciple makers and it would happen to
be it would happen
to multiply in a manner and that's what most of this
evening tonight is about is multiplying yourself multiplying
a manner that we could plant churches literally
all over some of
you don't know this but our state is
ask us the we
cooperate with the Baptist Churches all
over the state of Oklahoma, and they're currently six empty church
buildings that need planted.
Planted and right now,
we're just needing disciple makers to multiply
disciple makers so we can send disciple makers
to replant these churches. And so this is
the engine that it not just worshiped on
Sunday. See if I know how to do this. This is
what is it's every
Every week it's a mystery. So not just worship together.
Not just our big events. But Community groups. It's
kind of our Bell cow, which means that most of you are in
one but through those social relationships.
We try to develop Intimate Relationships.
So this right here is a
key where we have intimate relationships and we
can get to the the level of transparency and
intimacy and accountability in discipleship.
And what is a disciple
one who's following Jesus one who is being changed or
transformed by Jesus and one who's committed to the
mission of Jesus and that's disciple making you'll gonna
need to memorize that now what I
just said was is the large group you have to
remain silent.
Right, if you don't I mean
you have to stand up and sing when you're supposed to but then during the sermon you're supposed
to remain silent. So there's not a lot of conversation going on and if
there is you get in trouble your mom or perhaps a
deacon will thump you on the back of the head, but but
that's not the way it is. What we're trying to do is get to
this point over here where we have like we said transparency even
vulnerability intimacy and ultimately
accountability. All right, you see
I didn't even try the way you guys have made fun of me.
All right. So now this is the important part.
Okay, and I need everybody to pay attention. All
right. What is God done in your
micro group the last 12 weeks?
If you'll remember if you'll go back with me
12 weeks the very first night two,
very interesting thingies happened. And one is
I said, what we're
going to do in a minute is going to be really really awkward and I apologize
in advance.
We're going to we're going to get together in groups
of four and I said try not to do more than four and
you know, some of you busted the Only Rule
the very first night, but so we're
gonna try to get in groups of four and we're going to have a micro group
experiment and this is what I said.
That you're going to be surprised that in 12 weeks
how quickly we begin to bond together
as the supplementers and you're
going to get the sense the closeness and
the intimacy that comes through being able to be honest and
open and transparent with one another and so here
we are 12 weeks later and some of your groups are planting
on continuing and that really wasn't the plan
but if you know it what I've learned about baptist is just
tell them what to do. They're not going to do that thing. All right, but I'm
excited because now we have Micro groups. What I'm
gonna ask you to do is you see here hhbc.com forward
slash disciple I need
for you to go on there and I need for you to click the box that says
update or micro group update and just
register your micro group. We would love to be able to have some simple
Matrix saying that we're growing that
every year we have more disciples than the year before but
you'll have to communicate with me. All right, there's two
other boxes and one is I want to be discipled.
And the other one is I want to make disciples. And
so this is going to be our page where
we are putting groups together. Hopefully, you don't have
to go to that page that you've already been thinking and praying through about who
you're going to ask to be in your micro group. And if
so, then you'll just make an update and say this is our micro group
and this is when we meet where we meet and anyway, so
I ask that you do that as of last night.
We had two.
All right. Thank you. Oh, I see what we could do.
Let's see if we can crash the internet go ahead and pull your phone out Aha
and
that and listen to me if you're gonna come in church and fake signing up
for discipleship shame on you, right? But if
you want to during these testimonies, I
want you to go ahead and and register your
group or register whether you want to be in a disciple group or you
want to make disciples or register the group that you've already put together.
Well you do that.
All right. Now, let's talk about the next few minutes.
Hopefully more than a few.
I'm going to ask for testimonies the Bible says let
the redeemed of the Lord say so.
And so our our witness needs to be more than just showing
up showing up is very good, but it
needs to be more than that. It needs for you you need to be able to articulate what
God is doing in your life through
through this discipleship experiment.
And so I'm going
to ask that you not go longer than five minutes. I'm we
don't have a shepherd's crook. We're not going to pull you off,
but everyone in the room will know.
He's going too long or she won't be quiet. You
know is Phil gonna get up and say something, you know,
you don't want the room thinking that about
you. Okay. So three to five minutes what I'd
like you to do is share. What's what's
the Lord been doing? What's he been teaching you how has your
group grown together? And the purpose of this is just
to let you know that this even though it was an experiment. I
I have been convinced from very day
one that that you guys would really fall in
love with one another and just 12 short weeks what would happen if
you really started a micro group and really
begin to do this in Earnest for the right reasons and
not have to listen to me do this thing about
the you know that you really were studying the word of
God together. And then you were talking to one another
and asking important questions like we've been
talking about what would happen if after year what
would happen to your group and how would how would you grow in Christ?
And and so that's what we're trying to do now.
last thing and this is
This is a deal breaker for some of you but but I'm just going
to say I believe in you say I'm a courageous and I
am brave. I didn't think. So. Anyway, thank you.
Thank you, so.
We're going to videotape these testimonies and the reason why
is that we really believe that
and by the way, I don't have any transcripts. I
haven't passed out any scripts for people to read this is
going to be from your heart about what God has done in your group and we're
going to have an opportunity to capture just little
brief 30 second spots and share them on our
churches social media page because we believe in
this Township and discipleship is what we do and and there's
nothing more important than hearing from the
lips of a person whom God has made a difference.
And so I want to show you something real quick. I hope I have
this. Yes.
You can't see anybody, you know right there.
Can I can I just say real quickly? That's about the best
looking young man either ever see? Okay. So
the reason that I pulled this out of the archives.
is that
I've been telling you a story about when I was in 8th
grade how this guy comes to me and says, I want
you to pray about something and started my
very first discipleship experiment experience and
and come to find
out when I moved to Edmond I find out and I've
known that he also lives in Yukon.
And so he and I have been visiting back and forth
since we've moved back here and I asked him to be here tonight. And
so I want you to meet my minister of Youth Joe McKinney
Joe. Could you just stand up real quick? Yeah, let's welcome Joe
McKinney the beautiful wife, Diana.
Now in a minute when the Holy Spirit
begins to move and people are sharing testimonies. I wouldn't be
surprised if a Joe came and shared
and B. He went longer than five minutes.
But anyway, that's the challenge tonight. So, all
right. So what I like for you to
do is and I'm going to show you. Okay a
good disciple maker always models.
What he's asking the disciples in the
group to do so, I'm going to model for you and while I'm
sharing if you would like to share I'm going to have that you
come and sit on the front row. All right, I'm gonna ask that you
come and do it from the platform so that we can get a good lighting situation
for the video. If you don't want to be in video, just
let me know we won't post you on on the social
media page. Okay. So here we go.
And by the way, I'm supposed to do it in less than five
minutes. So you're gonna have to hustle to get down here and sit on the front row. All right,
I need Mark say go.
I haven't been in a micro group, so it didn't
really mean that much to me. I'm just kidding.
No, you guys have heard my stories of
all the things that God has allowed
me to do in Ministry funerals weddings.
Preaching teaching big events
biggest crowd. I think
I've ever spoken to is about 5,000 people.
of all of those things the thing that made the most
difference in my life and the thing that I fell in love with more than anything else
Is being a disciple maker?
And I want that experience for you.
And there's nobody on the front row.
Okay, Helen. Come on up.
Okay stand right here by this and hold that
microphone.
Introduce yourself and tell your story.
Hi, my name is Alisa Campbell and I have been
attending Henderson Hills for almost 20 years.
And Henderson Hills does so
many things great and I can say there's
a long list of things that have touched my heart but this disciple
should making has really touched my heart in
a different way. I guess all my life. I've grown up in
church and I knew about discipleship, but I had never been trained on
how to make a disciple. So this is
what it's meant to me in this group has been so special because of
the openness. Thank you, Carol for leading us letting us
be transparent and just the sharing so I'm
very excited about what comes next and I know
that it kind of prompted me to say in January.
I'm going to be stepping out and trying to make disciples in
a different way. So thank you Phil for what you're doing.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Helen. I've been coming to this
church for about three months four
months five months.
Five months. He's the reason I'm here. I followed him. I
live in Norman. I blame the
holy spirit, so
So that this has been the most wonderful experience. It
really has and I came with my daughter-in-law Holly
and
on the first night when we
made the group before we made the groups. I told her
we are not going to be in the
same group.
And she kind of looked at me like what?
Well, I kind of like making new friends. Anyway, we
ended up staying in the same group. We were joined
by three other wonderful ladies. It was four
on the first night. We did have somebody come out
a long later on.
And it's just been amazing.
I've been thinking about what I was going to say and I really I almost want
to cry I really do it's it's means that
much.
We have a little text group. We text
throughout the week. We stay in
contact with each other a few weeks ago when we
didn't have the evening. We actually still
got together and we went out for dinner in.
It's just the friendships that
we've made the bonds.
And we are one of the groups that's going to carry on
and work further into the
Bible and grow together, and
we're a little scared about taking
that other step, but I
truly think that's something that we will do. This has been amazing. Thank
you. Thank you.
Okay.
By the way, you keep coming down during the testimony. So who's
that? We need somebody on this road right here.
Hello, my name is Gabriel Craig. I've been coming
to Henderson since about February of this year
whenever I moved to Oklahoma, so I'm originally
Missouri boy graduated college
recently and all my friends pretty much
like went in different directions. So it was really tough to
keep that community in person. And
I knew coming to Henderson and just experiencing some
of the community groups that Community was like something
that I really valued and then they started
the discipleship and I was like cool. I've been through a lot
of discipleship stuff. I also want to
just get to know more of the church body that I've
come to love already and it
was really cool because
When I first got placed into our micro
group, I was like man I am I'm like the youngest
guy here but like 30 years. So I was
like, I was just sponge mode just absorbing all the
wisdom that our guys brought to the table, but it was really awesome
that they were
they were vulnerable with me in my
past experiences and allowed me to share which
I thought wasn't going to be the case since I
had left my college friends and it was really cool to see
how we just bonded like we've been friends
forever. Like I said, I've only been here since February but
I feel like I've known these guys for years now and
it's just been awesome to see how God has
been moving through us through our group through. We just
text constantly and like someday some days at work. It's almost
just like the holy spirit is just like hey Gabe's not having a good day and
I just get a reach out from someone and it's just super awesome.
Just living the gospel out in our group and we have
plans to take what
we've learned here and Branch out and our different fields of
work outside of church and it's super cool to see
what all we are going to be doing and staying in
touch. So yeah great job.
My name is Brianna and I've been
coming to Henderson Hills for about four years
now.
And I'm the one that has the
screechy baby in the back. Sometimes she's very loud and
very very vocal. So the
first night I feel like I have to like preface everything
and talk about the before but the first night whenever he came
in and was like we're gonna make small groups and then called
people out for like wanting to leave out of the door. That was
me.
And I didn't do it but it like crossed my mind. I was like, how can I
leave without noticing I was like should I pinch the baby? She could
start crying I could leave like
I tried to figure out every way to get out but he called us
out and made me feel bad as I was like, okay, I'm gonna stay and then
Jenny came and she stood next kind of
to me. So I was like, okay, I have the baby. I have all my stuff. I can't walk very
far. So I stood next to Jenny and then Emily
joined us and Emily and I've known each other a little bit our boys
her youngest in my oldest or in
the same grade. So I was like, okay Lisa. I know someone like
Makes me feel a little bit better. So I had Emily Jenny
and then Lindy and I did not know Lindy or
really Jenny. I had just seen her around and we
just got to talking and
It was just I was so nervous at first but every
week we came back and we kind of joked that we were
the gold star group because we didn't miss a
single Wednesday for a very long time.
And at one point. My husband was like are you
giving yourself the gold star or is this like a known thing?
I was like, oh, we just think that ourselves we are giving ourselves the gold star
because our perfect attendance.
But anyways, we ended up not having perfect attendance,
but we did really good for a long time.
And anyway, so one day
after Wednesday, Lindy and I were talking and
she was like, why don't you come try our community group and her
engineer actually in the same community group.
And so I said, yeah, we'll come try and
my husband and I we have a weird schedule. So we've been looking
but we've never found something that really worked or
clicked. But the first time we walked into Ginny and
Lindy's community group it was
Perfect. It felt like God's timing. He had
been having this group for us and we walked
in and we just felt at home and my husband's
like so we found our group right and I was like, yeah, and we ended
up joining just a couple weeks later. So this group not
only gave me those three friends, but it gave us
13 other couples.
That we're now friends with and part of a group. So, I
don't know that's like amazing to me that just this class has done
that from me wanting to escape out of the doors too. Now
a an amazing community group
of people. So I'm very thankful for that. Amen. Amen.
so, I don't know if you noticed but that is the
That's the pathway in the pathway doesn't just go
One Direction. Sometimes it goes other directions and Jimmy
Quinn who's our connections Pastor
brought me your your every
person who joins the church gets an interview and in
the interview, she said I I thought we'd found
our church, but when I got involved in a micro group, and then that became my
church and so I was hoping you'd share very good.
Come ahead.
Wow, it's really intimidating being up here on how you
do this. All of a suddenly. Wow, Lana Dickinson.
Glad to see you Phil. I have to say this has
been Joy because we have collectively gotten
to know you through this and it's been fun
to see your heart. We got to know Phil the
first day he was here and really got to hear his
heart for the church his heart for discipleship. And so
coming and doing this has been really really fun because we've
been able to sort of see your passion come
alive. So thank you for sharing it with us.
For us the micro group really was
a Divine appointment we connected
with some old friends that we had known from another community group.
We all got back together. It just so happened that we
kind of collectively had the eye roll when
When you said we had to do a micro group and so
we just joined together and it turned out to be just such
a sweet thing. God really
used this time to reconnect us. But
also it was at a critical time when we really needed the the
safety of the micro group because we
were all dealing with some some really intense things. So I'm
really grateful each week was a Divine appointment
and each week. We just saw God move and
deepen and so we all have a different direction we're going
to go but we're really grateful that you sort of
made us do this and that you told us
we we had to stick to it. And then you you kind of told us
that we really needed to seek the Holy Spirit on this so and we
have and we're grateful that you kind of gave us
the kick to do it.
Very good. Good job, Atlanta.
We're not keeping score but the girls are way ahead
gentlemen.
but
No, the I will make it while we're waiting
for the next person to come forward. I'll make a couple of observations and
that is that the bigger
groups are more comfortable.
and the smaller groups are a little more intimidating and
that we did have people walk out because it
was too much to ask and
one of the elders
You know, I hadn't been here very long. So you got to keep those Elders happy
amen. And so one of
the elders came to me the very first night he goes. You know, what?
Took a lot of Courage.
He didn't say it was a bad idea just said it took a lot of Courage, right
and anyway, and sure enough. I was
praying that it would go the way that it has and isn't it?
Good to see how God is at work in the lives of
his people.
And isn't it sad to know?
The will not allow him to work in ways that he wants to
because we're not comfortable with being
uncomfortable. And so when we step out
in faith
It's kind of like the mission field, you know, if you wanted to
go where it was comfortable the the word would never spread but you
go out in faith and you believe and you find and you're in
a different culture, and it's not comfortable and you have to learn a little language and before you
know it it's your calling and it feels like home.
So anybody else? I'll hold
this for a little bit longer.
Don't all Rush at the same time looked like
a stampede. Come on. Yeah. All right. The fellows
are making a comeback.
Hello, my name is Marcus Hernandez in I have
to say God.
God had used this small group to
encourage my life tremendously when the first
night came and Phil said, okay, those ones
are gonna lead, please stand on the side
and then everybody else go ahead and select someone go
up and meet one of the the
leaders on the side. I thought oh, that's
a bad idea because I thought I'm gonna be like pick
me, you know,
but God did brought amazing people to
our group with Bob Conrad.
And Bob Delano and it's just
been a blessing to to have these
older gentle and actually poor him to my life and he's
just been great being able to
talk to them and get together and pray for each other
and encourage each other and as we were
talking we also saw we you know, I don't know, how am I
gonna do this? Probably just gonna pray and ask God just
to bring people to my life and sure enough. I got
a text from my son-in-law.
He said hey Marcus, would you
like to get together?
All right, though.
Yes, let's get together. So for me
to say that I have the privilege to
get together with my son-in-law.
To share the gospel to encourage each other.
It's just been a blessing. So I'll take that opportunity anytime
and then I'm getting together
with a couple of guys from rcg and eventually I
hope that we can all continue doing
this. It's been a blessing and thank God
for
for this opportunity to do the small groups.
Thank you Marcus. Good. Yeah.
All right. Who else?
going once
So tonight we're
talking about multiply your life going twice.
Jesus' disciples committed to the Great Commission
and were empowered by the Holy Spirit and the movement that Jesus
started is still moving forward still growing ever-expanding
to the ends of the Earth. You
guys know that Matthew wrote that when the
when all the nations have heard the gospel, then the
end will come and he's going to accomplish this through discipleship.
Did you know that this week for the first time in
human history eight billion people now inhabit the
planet and there's no way a church can grow fast enough
to reach everybody. But if one person would multiply
themselves every year it would happen within the next 15
years.
So, can you join this movement? The Amper answer
is simple multiply your life by making examples.
Here's just a real quick. Graphic. This is
the your quad. This is your micro
group. And if everyone does that you can just see that any
in less than a year. We'll have I don't
know how many of you are going to do it, but just from one to 36 in
one year.
I want to read to you something that
kind of.
It moved me
when I began to see the the heart of
my savior. He knows all he's
100% God and 100% man.
But in this passage, we see what something that
pleases him something that makes him smile one day.
We all hope to hear well done my good and faithful
servant and I'm going to show you how you can make that happen and Jesus
sins 72 with directions. Okay,
he sends them. It's kind of like what we
did on the first night. We're gonna put you in micro groups and you're like, oh but
they return look at verse 17
the 72 returned with joy.
So they come back and they find the joys. We have found it Lord. Even
the demons are subject to us in your name and he
said to them. Oh look at here.
y'all
Have mercy all right, keep them coming. Is that what you if
it's you you've got to stop?
Okay.
If I found out who it is, there's gonna be there's gonna be problems.
All right.
No, I should answer it.
Oh, this is my mom. Yeah, okay.
by the way, she loves talk to me every
evening and so
We're not gonna do FaceTime
Okay, here we go, and it might happen another six times so we'll
laugh every time okay.
And Jesus said to them I saw Satan
fall like lightning from heaven.
Behold, I have given you authority to tread on serpents and
scorpions and over the power of the enemy and nothing shall hurt. You
nevertheless do not rejoice in this that the
spirits are subject to you, but Rejoice that
your names are written in heaven.
And look at verse 21. This is that this is where kind of my heart left a little
bit. This is Jesus in that same hour. He rejoiced
in the Holy Spirit.
Seeing them come back and seeing them rejoicing.
The the Holy Spirit has worked through them to impact the lives
of people who needed it.
Said I thank you Father Lord of Heaven and Earth
that you've hidden these things from the wise and understanding
and revealed them to Little Children. Yes Father for such
was your gracious will so what if
God through the power of
the holy spirit is igniting a movement in US?
That we understand what it looks like.
Step out of our comfort zone to do something that makes us
feel uncomfortable even awkward and then see
God doing something special and to know that that brings
us joy and that it brings Jesus Joy is
enough for me. Okay?
now
What are we going to do next?
Well, I think that's all I think that's what we're gonna do.
This will be your last time to meet with your micro group. Unless
you guys are keeping on going Joe. Did you want to say something this evening?
All right. Well let Joe McKinney my minister of Youth
by the way, he asked me and I held I
was and the answer is too old to be in the
youth group. But anyway, come on ahead Joe.
I know that some of you were choked up.
greater
That has grown to such a man
of influence.
integrity
character
did you know?
That in your micro group.
There may be a young Christian.
Just like this guy was in the eighth grade.
pray that it's not in your group, but
When he was getting the call from surely his mother I
I thought he
says this what are you doing this? That's something
that he would have done in the
eighth grade.
our first group
all were eighth graders.
out of that group came pastors
staff members
missionaries
lawyers
district attorney
congressman
the influence that you can have
from the micro groups
from the small group that you create.
You can't imagine the influence that could
have.
And think if that was happening.
Not 10 or 12 groups.
But a hundred or two hundred groups, sorry.
and
I know it's intimidating and it's scary.
I find it easier to stand in front of a whole big group than
being in a group of four
but I
I was just
thinking my pastor often says
I'm more afraid.
of missed opportunities
then change
being uncomfortable
is change that's different for you. You're uncomfortable.
You're out of your comfort zone.
And that's hard.
But I'd be more afraid.
of a missed opportunity
And he didn't ask me to say this and it may be run conflict
with.
but at some point
especially and I don't know that there is
but can you see a brand new Christian?
by the way, how
how much ahead of somebody do you have to be to lead
them?
Well, you have to you can't go somewhere. You've never been right?
But you have to be one step. That's right.
That one step.
A young Christian could get together three others that
may be brand new Christians or maybe lost.
And he asked somebody else to come in and lead the group.
Can you imagine what could happen out of that?
But it may or may not happen in the large group.
I've got a group of guys that I'm teaching in the
morning at 6 o'clock.
And we're studying through the book of Hebrews.
and the last
my section that I'm teaching
tomorrow is the last few verses of chapter 5 in
the first eight verses of chapter 6.
and the passage in
chapter 6
has been said by most as the most controversial passage
in all of scripture.
But it follows.
The preacher who's written the letter to Hebrews these
Jewish Christians.
wherefore at a time
that you ought to be teaching others.
You have a need to be taught yourself.
And the lady who shared I've been in church
all my life.
I've heard about discipleship.
But I didn't know how to make disciples.
What a great thing to learn
now.
And I've discovered that you know, you become a
Christian and for the first maybe months or
years.
You're just learning.
about your conversion
You're learning what it means to be a Christian.
And then you begin to grow more.
And you begin to have quiet times.
and memorize scripture
learn how to share your faith
and that's a growing disciple.
But listen you haven't arrived.
Till you start making disciples.
And so I am so thrilled.
With what God's doing here.
at Henderson Hills
and how he's using my boy.
to impact your lives
Thank you, buddy. Thank you.
How long did he go? He said it was more than five. I'm
not counting. Hey, I want us to pray together and then
meet together with your micro group and I'll come
and remind you about 40 minutes, but it's 7:30. Okay, let's pray
father. Thank you so much for what you're doing in the life
of our church.
I love to dream about what you could do through
the power of your spirit and through our obedience Lord. I
love to hear stories in a year about what you've done and how
you begin to multiply disciples in
our church Lord. We don't want us
to talk about this.
We want to experience it.
And we want to see you rejoice in
our obedience and in the fruit that you bring.
Lord You're a good God and in just 12 weeks we've
seen you do Miracles and we're we're thankful for that. And so we
Rejoice tonight be with these groups Lord. Let them
some are closing up this evening and some are
just getting started but be with them and speak through them in Jesus name.
Amen.
I hate to interrupt anything that's happening right now,
but it is almost 7:30 and I wanted to take a couple minutes before
we officially wrap this up.
So you can push pause on whatever you're talking
about for a second and then you can continue after in a moment, but
I just wanted to say before you all there
were a couple people slipped out, but I wanted to say before all
of you left just
There are a few times in a role.
Like I have like Phil has like others have that you are
just really proud of what God is doing.
And tonight's one of those and this whole semester has
been one of those for me as I've watched. God used
Phil and use you all.
To do what you've seen God do and you heard
glimpses of that tonight, you know, even if
you didn't share what God's done in your heart in this season.
And whether you continue as a group now or not you
now have the tools you feel hopefully more
equipped and trained to be able to do what we've done here
tonight to continue the ministry of God's spirit
through his people.
Through his word through the church all of
that because as you've heard tonight about the
movement, the idea comes from God's word first,
but then as as we've heard from our vision and our our idea
of what God wants to do is to be a church
that glorifies him by becoming this hub for an
all ages disciple making movement.
And that word movement is just that it multiplies and multiplies and
multiplies out Generations.
And as you know compound interest and all
of that takes off whenever you start to multiply multiplication,
and that's the goal is that we can't reach Edmonds.
We can't reach Oklahoma City. We can't reach the
state. We can't reach the nation. We can't reach the world without multiplication happening.
And that's what this is. Hopefully sparking in
us that that what you're doing right now is becoming the
norm rather than the exception at
Henderson Hills.
That this becomes what we all do.
I mean, I'm tomorrow morning six. Am I got my group going and
that this is what we do rather than like what
what are you doing? What what this group of three four people? What
what is that? Exactly tell us that this is just who we
are.
Because it's really where the life change.
In most cases will happen.
So I just want to say thank you from my position for
what you have invested in and just dove into
without even knowing what you're diving into us. Brianna said
earlier just the opportunities to
do this on a Wednesday night take advantage of the
time use this semester Just To See
God do something in you first and then through you
into other people you can see you're a minister you're used
by God in each other's lives.
So don't take that lightly.
I don't take that opportunity for granted.
But realize that there are a lot
of people sitting in this room on a Sunday or in
your community groups that don't have anything like
this it is scary it is intimidating but there's
there's a step of Faith taken that you have taken
and you are just one step ahead of where they are and
you can see what God did in you what you can see happen in
them, that's what our prayer is I want to kind of
commission you tonight a little bit with that with the the idea
to say let's let's see this expand and
multiply into our church just normal
This is just who we are as disciples We
Make Disciples intentionally.
And so you can go as we talk about your scent. You
can go sent by the Lord from this place either to
continue your group or to start new groups. However, the Lord
leads but we're behind you. We're for you.
I'm excited to be a part of this with you. It's an
honor really is to see how God has moved in this way.
So thank you Phil for leading this for the last 12 weeks and
we're grateful for all of you besting in it. Let
me pray for us and then you can continue and and be done tonight God
we're grateful.
What a gift it is to be a part.
of your work in this world
You don't have to use us.
but you've chosen to
And what an honor?
What a privilege.
So I pray for each one of these and those who've already
left tonight those who couldn't be here tonight.
I pray that they would feel.
just feel your
your love for them.
Your presence with them like Matthew 28 says Jesus. You're never gonna
leave us alone in this journey.
You have the authority you have.
Or have our devotion and you are with us and so we
know that you will use that.
So help us Lord.
For those who feel intimidated by starting out a new
group.
Give them courage.
For those who feel ashamed because of their past
give them freedom.
For those who?
Want to be used by You For Your Glory God
give them opportunities.
Thank you again for this time that we've had.
May not stop here tonight.
This is not just a class. This is not something
we can check the box off. This is a launching pad.
To your ministry in this church and by extension
into our city to change Edmund into
our metropolitan area to change
Oklahoma City and then into the nation's including our
own this is what you want to do through us.
where who knows where that one person in our micro group
our D group can
can take a step of faith. We can't take right now in our lives
and we can see them go to an unreached people group and change
lives there and seek God work and
miraculous ways. Who knows God?
What you're going to do through this as we're faithful, it's all
you want from us is faithfulness obedience worship.
So we pray to give it to you we would give it to
you.
Both in worship Gatherings, but also every moment
of every day you're worthy of it.
Thank you again. What a gift to my soul. This
has been to see tonight and to see this semester. You are
good to us. God may we
give our lives in response in Jesus name? Amen? Amen. Love
you all. Thank you. You are sent.